[Music]
the Rich Roll podcast
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast so
last month with some admitted
trepidation I took a little step outside
my comfort zone to post my first
monologue episode for those that
listened you know that I was quite
Unsure how it would be received half
expecting it might just land with a
silent thud but instead to my delight it
was widely embraced further evidence of
course that growth occurs when the
courage to scratch the creative itch
trumps the fear of how the offering will
be received
it's fear that keeps us paralyzed it
keeps us small muted underexpressed but
courage on the other hand leads to
action not that what I did was
courageous in any way just illustrating
the point that
this is what you got to do and that
success or failure is unimportant really
in comparison to the opportunity for
learning for expansion and the growth
that follows this is all a long way of
saying that confronting working through
and overcoming what Stephen pressfield
calls resistance is always worth it
so in any event the response to that
monologue being essentially positive
episode 747 in case you missed it a
meditation on our complicated
relationship with the digital world was
encouraging encouraging enough for me to
give this another spin despite being in
the throes of some pretty extreme jet
lag at the moment having just returned
from Europe last night all of which is a
transparent disclaimer for the quality
of my articulation today in any event
I'm often asked what my podcast is about
how I Define the lens through which I
approach public conversation and it's a
difficult question to answer because the
podcast really isn't about any one thing
on a basic level I suppose it's an
external projection of my interior self
an extension of my curiosity at a
specific moment shared publicly in real
time
and as such I tend to cast a wide net
following that Curiosity to Traverse a
pretty wide spectrum of topics with a
broad diversity of all kinds of
individuals of varying perspective so
how does one concisely Define a show
that explores The Perils of addiction
environmental awareness how to best
parent teens the future of AI the limits
of athletic potential or how to
understand Consciousness extend health
span and what it means to pursue a
meaningful life well I've spent quite a
bit of time thinking about this and
really the best answer I can come up
with a singular unifying theme that
captures the essence of what I'm
grappling with and what I'm trying to
understand and what I'm trying to share
is the nature of transformation
in other words
how exactly does one go from where are
they currently reside physically
mentally emotionally spiritually to
where they aspire to be to Traverse the
Delta the difference the terrain of
space-time that exists between point a
who and where you are now to point B the
future self of your imagination
this topic
transformation I think is pretty
Universal in its applicability because
irrespective of who you are or where you
find yourself in life we all all of us
Harbor this inherent animating energy
this
aspiration that's built into US be it a
whisper or in some a roar to change to
alter to improve in some way our lot in
life some find this process easier and
more facile than others those who
successfully change for the better even
if that changes minute put themselves in
a position to experience an altered
state of self that expands the aperture
of possibility it's like this shift in
potential energy that breeds confidence
that engenders optimism and encourages
further exploration into one's untapped
potential
the result not surprisingly is more
action and when that action even in
microscopic form is compounded a
precious momentum begins to emerge that
over time produces this amazing
self-perpetuating cycle of positive
change uh continually
reinforcing growth accelerating
potential elevating generator of
transformation powerful enough to
actually and quite literally as a matter
of fact constructively reconstruct an
individual top to bottom wholesale and
not for nothing all the people that that
person happens to come into contact with
as well
on the other hand there's a whole set of
other people on the other side perhaps
most of us
that find change Elusive and for some
impossible even this like fickle shiny
object of desire that's just Out Of
Reach always just Out Of Reach and
despite the same desire to change
somehow for this group of people it just
remains out of grasp
there might be intermittent bursts of
inspiration or motivation but that
always Fades quickly and it's unable to
sustain the occasional fits and starts
at expansion that somehow always
ultimately contract like snap back to
the norm
and that's something that gets processed
as failure
failure that over time dampens the
spirit undermines confidence and keeps
us stuck Keeps Us defeated paralyzed our
souls eroded we end up relinquishing
even the attempt
living out the remainder of our days and
what Henry David Thoreau characterized
as a quiet resignation to a life of
desperation
so
the questions
reduced to their Essence are
why is it exactly that some can change
and others cannot
what are
the determining qualities or variables
that predict growth and expansion over
regression or resignation
is it simply a matter of will
to what extent do things like social
conditioning environment pain childhood
trauma
socioeconomic disparity and a whole
mishmash Myriad of other very important
crucial factors play into the equation
if the process of transformation was
merely this matter of logic or
rationality then wouldn't it make sense
that education access to good
information shouldn't that translate
into taking the correct actions required
to progress towards one's goal growth or
ambition because whatever your problem
whatever your obstacle your handicap be
it academic psychological emotional
economic physical mental spiritual
that problem
most likely isn't unique it's already
been studied it's understood the
solution probably already exists there's
counsel that can be found in countless
academic philosophical and spiritual
texts dating back Millennia or in the
thousands of self-help books that get
published annually what about in the
exchanges with friends or family or
mentors or colleagues or in your chosen
Hall of worship this is information that
flows freely and endlessly in our social
media feeds if you want X then you do y
problem solved
obviously change doesn't work this way
most of us struggle mightily to square
the equation because transformation
isn't math it isn't binary it isn't
linear
it's messy it's complex infinitely
complex
it's confounding in what activates it
it's even more mysterious what sustains
it and this thing transformation change
is apparently incredibly resistant to
even the most practical actionable
objective and obvious advice delivered
from the most trusted and respected
source
so then what is it what is the nature
and shape of this thing we call
transformation
well to understand this is to invite
Paradox into your life
because transformation the how the when
and the why of change
I have come to believe is a landscape of
dichotomies
it is both an art and a science
it is a mindset but also a practice it's
an action but it's also a Stillness it
is both spiritual and practical a Yin
and a Yang that entails on the one hand
this bricklayer approach to doing that
can produce Progressive change over time
and on the other hand and perhaps more
importantly it's this ethereal
mystical way of being not doing but
being that makes space for those
lightning bolt moments that can forever
alter a life in the blink of an eye
it's also as someone who has navigated
more than a few chapters of
transformation in my 56 years and hosted
a zillion conversations on the topic a
subject matter uh terrain that cannot be
properly covered or grasped in a single
conversation or certainly not by way of
a brief monologue such as this but we
can enter this realm we can find a way
into the process of trying to better
understand transformation how to
approach it how to practice it how to
pursue it and embody it
with a thought from the great Mark Twain
who said quote the two most important
days in your life are the day you were
born and the day you find out why now
I'm sure there are many interpretations
of this quote
mine is that each and every one of us
has arrived here
right now in this human form fully
equipped with a unique never before and
never will be seen again
manifestation of consciousness
a Divine Spark all your own and unlike
any other in utterly original
repository of potential expression
living latent lurking dormant within us
typically
compartmentalized likely even repressed
yet patiently awaiting discovery
occasionally every once in a while
reminding you of its Presence by
elevating your soul when you are in tune
with it or
turning your gut when deep down you know
you're off track
I choose to believe we are here to
evolve it is our purpose to grow to
progress towards the most authentic and
fully actualized embodiment of that
unique expression
to become who we truly are not who our
parents want us to be not who we are
convinced Society requires us to be nor
the person our environments have
unconsciously programmed us to become
but to instead
step into and claim our most authentic
self-actualized selves that version of
self where there is no daylight between
who we are and who we aspire to become
and no mask that hides us from others or
ourselves now whether or not this belief
of mine is true in a literal sense is
actually less important to me than the
power it holds as an operating system
for Life an approach to guide actions to
guide decisions with
greater intentionality that has
engendered my life with a greater sense
of purpose
Direction and meaning
key to decoding one's Y is action of
course the Y is revealed through the
doing but that action must be coupled
with an incredible commitment to going
inward to stripping away the layers of
our crafted personalities discarding
those masks and deconstructing the
narratives the tired and calcified
Stories We Tell ourselves time and time
again about who we are what we're
capable of what we're not capable of and
why these stories that we have
unconsciously created and reinforced
over years sometimes decades to make us
feel safe it's time to set them aside
and instead it's time to get real with
ourselves to connect with and cultivate
a relationship with that Divine Spark
the simple but likely discarded hidden
or buried things beneath and Beyond the
story
that bring us joy or brought us joy
during the innocence of Youth the little
things that made us feel like ourselves
before
self-consciousness entered before our
defense mechanisms took over entered the
picture
and muted that stuff or snuffed them out
or extinguish them all together
this process mining one's interior
attuning to the heart uncovering that
Divine spark connecting with the
authentic self Within
it's all the same stuff don't get lost
in the terminology there are many ways
to characterize it but the point is all
of these things demand quiet
it's a subtle art
it's a subtle practice that requires you
Venture beyond the incessant
self-imposed distractions that
increasingly imprison us and go instead
to this place where
you can actually hear and heed those
faint Whispers
where is that place
solitude
presence is the Resonance of potential
this is where Twain's y lives
and it is these Whispers that remind us
of Who We Are
who we are meant to be
how do we do this
meditation
mindfulness
ah meditation's not for me mindfulness
is [__] you don't understand how
busy I am it's easy for you to say my
life is complicated fine I get it
go take a walk instead
the truth is
most people
will do anything literally anything to
avoid the agonizing Prospect of Simply
sitting quiet and alone with oneself
most will ignore the tug
insistent on remaining disconnected in a
state of persistent terminal distraction
dutifully and reactively subscribing to
that thorough life of quiet desperation
or what Dr Gabor mate would call
the disease of inauthenticity
a disease that's marked by disconnection
from self that often originates from
untreated trauma is then reinforced by
defense mechanisms that over time and
left untreated
can metastasize into actual physical
illness
now I'm not suggesting you cast your
life aside or that you feel burdened to
reinvent yourself overnight this is not
about quitting your job or shirking
responsibilities we all live in the
world and life is [__] hard
I'm simply saying
don't ignore the tug
find a way to spend some time even if
it's a few moments in focused attention
on the heart away from the head
and understand that life is not static
wherever you find yourself
each thought that you entertain each
decision you make every interaction with
another person either moves you towards
greater congruity with that authentic
self Within
or indulges the disease of
inauthenticity
one truth I've discovered through
personal experience is that the further
you move away from that congruity
the louder the universe will knock
and the more forceful it will beckon
your attention the more your gut will
turn the more disconnected and out of
sorts you're going to feel
the more you're going to feel like a
stranger in your own life
resistance to heat that knock will only
deepen that sense of disconnection and
the knocks they're going to continue
they're going to get louder and louder
each knock more destabilizing than the
prior until the pain of your
circumstance is so intense that it
exceeds the extreme fear of change you
Harbor will you finally summon the
willingness to consider a different way
let's face it pain is a great motivator
it definitely prompted most of the major
life Transformations I've traversed
but the great irony here is that we
actually don't need to be in pain to
change
each and every moment presents a new
opportunity
for greater honesty
for better connection with self and for
contrary action to make a new and
different choice for greater authentic
expression and in turn growth
to embrace a positive change even in the
most micro sense in the absence of pain
is an incredible Act of self-love that
we can all practice that is freely
available that we all deserve and need
not be earned
it's also a gift to others and it's
something that becomes easier and more
reflexive in direct proportion to our
commitment to honoring greater
authenticity to living an examined life
not from The Limited perspective of our
intellect
but from the musings of the heart
a frequency best attuned when we
disconnect from distraction
invest in solitude and get present with
ourselves
do this without attachment to where it
may lead
and you just might meet yourself
for the very first time
and while you're at it
stop hiding stop apologizing for who you
are stop waiting or someone else to
solve your problems for you
because you
are the one you've been waiting for
because the world needs the best version
of you
and because the clock
is ticking
thank you for indulging me
I hope you found this valuable
and I'll see you back here soon
peace
[Music]